this is the scene in London today as the
city is decorating and working out the
final details for the king's coronation
in just 15 days
a source tells E.T Katy Perry is excited
to be performing at the coronation
concert it's really gonna be super fun
Larger than Life
we're told Katie's man Orlando has been
a solid source of support as for her
royal prep our source says Katie is
hell-bent on clean eating meditation and
managing stress better yesterday we did
TM which is something I do all the time
Transcendental Meditation I loved it
[Music]
Katie and I are going to represent
American Idol it's an honor Lionel's
youngest daughter Sophia meanwhile is
getting married this weekend in the
south of France that's her in white
kissing Beyonce Elliot Grange as they
head to their rehearsal dinner we're
told Sophia is set to wear a Chanel
dress and is beyond ecstatic it's a
whole weekend Affair back to the UK
where the Royals released this
photograph of the queen on what would
have been her 97th birthday the pick
taken by Princess Kate shows her late
Majesty with some of her grandchildren
and great-grandchildren missing Harry
and Megan's kids Archie and lillibet yep
things are still tense between the
former Fab Four a source close to the
royal family tells E.T William is still
upset about Harry's book he feels it was
a betrayal and he has no interest in
communicating with Harry before the
coronation
right now will is however going viral
today for a different reason the prince
was happy to jump in and help answer the
phone at an Indian restaurant he and
Kate were visiting you're gonna trade it
free okay will book The unsuspecting
caller a table for two what name is
foreign